hi I'm Scott dad is from wired i'm
sitting here because of michael haney at
GQ who challenged me with the ice bucket
challenge now while I've already donated
to fund ALS research I did think it
would be fun to break this challenge
down wired style you see the probability
of nominating someone who hasn't had ice
dumped on their head depends directly on
the number of people who have had I
stumped on their head / the entire
population of Earth so by my math that
would put us at late-september at that
point just about every single person
would have had i stumped on their head
now my math maybe a little bit off my
math might be a little bit off but one
thing I'm sure of is that Carlton Cuse
Chris Hardwick and Cindy levy you're up
next for more information go to ALS
a.org thanks